yeah it's insane
um can I just like get along yeah tell
me about it yeah why can't we
[__] there's always these outliers
you know is it like religion religion
plays a bit like religion does great
beautiful things yeah you know
um like the The Fringe ideas I'm in
Eastern Europe a lot right now and I was
you know in Afghanistan during the fall
of Afghanistan and the number of
religious
non-profits that were helping the
ukrainians helping orphans sending in
humanitarian Aid to the front lines
Medical Aid you know the Samaritan purse
and then Afghanistan you like the the
Argo airlift and Glenn Beck like I know
so what did easy do to throw darts at
that guy spent
tens of millions of dollars helping
evacuate people out of Afghanistan that
we're going to be tortured by the
Taliban you know so like you got the
Mother Teresa on one end of the spectrum
you know and then you have priests
molesting kids yeah you know and like if
we're gonna throw that all under
underneath religion then that kind of
sucks but
yeah and and everything in human nature
is that spectrum of like greatness to
Absolute douchebags
yeah so I'm sure religion but also just
human humans yeah humans so so when you
say that you're in Eastern Europe a lot
my God that's related to the Ukraine
conflict yeah yeah I got back like
five days ago
and and uh it went straight to honey
since someone was saying that the
Ukraine war is like the longest running
like something like since World War II
like
it's older than that
um the the people that built Moscow are
were from Kiev
right but the uh just this this one war
right
this conflict within the Vietnam go for
like 20 something years yeah I mean it
but like I don't know if I forget what
the metrics were but like it's like we
don't we don't appreciate in America
like the gravity the the extent of this
conflict
ukrainians started training in
resistance
um a generation ago they started
teaching kids as young as eight years
old and we it was really easy for
propaganda wise the Russians to label
you know fascists and Nazis because of
the things that they saw in schools and
what we saw in schools was the
ukrainians training their young men how
to prepare to fight and a lot of those
things out of context look very like
authoritarian and very fascist and like
the worst enemy of a communist is a
fascist and the Ukrainian government was
training their young men to prepare for
exactly what happened which was a
Russian invasion across an
internationally recognized Sovereign
border and uh mass murder war crimes of
like absolute genocide they're trying to
erase a race
right now
and the everything that we're seeing in
the news about how the Russian troops
are just like
[__] and and you know like well like
their bombs weren't exploding and
they're abandoning all their stuff
they're like just losing retreating is
that the media spinning it a little bit
I mean they're a third world country
with the nukes Russia is you know these
Russian troops
um were in bad Health you know like bad
Dental Health bad Vision bad skin old
equipment you know seeing them firsthand
you're like good you're a soldier
especially like seeing American soldiers
to have like great equipment you know
and they're healthy and they take
physical tests you know and every year
they have dental and vision like all of
our soldiers are very like the vast
majority are very very healthy and then
you go over there like what the heck
what is wrong with you yeah
um but
it's a number game
the Russians can throw bodies at this
problem for forever and
um
it's also a way for them to get rid of
certain populations within Russia that
they want to kill
so that's where their draft comes in
yeah that's right they're called scripts
or the poor
um
ethnically groups that they don't care
about
so so they they'll
um Mike
designed the draft to bring in
ethnicities
that's right wow
that's not like a little bit like that's
100 correct wow yeah so that's uh
communism bro
it's bad it's it's not really really
really bad until you get to see what
it's really like and how bad it is where
there's somebody that's like all right
we're going to take 300 conscripts and
I'm going to hand pick the groups and
ethnicities that these people are coming
from
yeah wow it's called Stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
Amazon and type in Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and Order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of Amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on Amazon and
buy Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude